maître lagjibibé vous êtes un témoin
privilégié des travaux passés sur
l'évolution statutaire avez-vous
l'impression que cette nouvelle
organisation a facilité les échanges
avec l'État je vais anticiper votre
réponse pouvez-vous nous dire sur quel
point les nouveaux travaux menés
actuellement par les élus guyanais
doivent s'accentuer pour fluidifier et
simplifier ces échanges sur le débat
statutaire bon
euh moi j'ai toujours dit que les débats
sur l'évolution ou ce que j'ais appeler
l'adaptation l'occurrence statutaire
puisque pour moi il s'agit en
l'occurrence de modifier des textes un
statut et de rendre compatible avec son
son bassin de vie sauf qu'il faut qu'on
fasse attention à une chose j'ai
toujours
dit que une adaptation d' évolution ne
réglera qu'une partie des problèmes
pourquoi et si j'ai tenu à le dire que
les crises sociétales majeur qui sont
jhuuit metaz en en cause des compétences
régaliennes c'est parce que rien ne sera
réglé l'évolution de l'autonomie moi je
je suis un Ardant partisan de
l'autonomie euh mais ne réglera pas pour
autant les problèmes effectivement
régaliens qui resteront à l'état ce sont
des compétences qui ne pourront pas être
transférées d'ailleurs pour des raisons
qu'on comprend très bien de liberté
publique de sécurité et cetera que si la
liberté devait effectivement changer
d'un territoire à l'autre euh en
fonction de conjoncture politique ça
sera extrêmement dangereux et moi je je
suis totalement opposé donc parce que je
suis un défenseur farouche des libertés
mais si je comprends il y a des
problématiques fortes donc euh je veux
dire que il faut qu'on reste et puis il
faut pas qu'on oublie aussi qu'est-ce
que la France la France c'est un État
unitaire c'est pas un État fédéral c'est
pas un état régional je je vois je vois
qu'effectivement parfois il y a euh il y
a des évolutions qui amènent à fait à
des réflexions euh c'est pour ça que je
me rattaque plutôt à la proposition du
Sénat qui pour moi effectivement
proposition de de bon sens et et qui
tient compte de de de d'une réalité